that's my doing my my stretches my my
gotta get warmed up for this hey
everyone I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I eat in a
day a youtuber review is a fit shorty
eats because I got asked so many times
to review this one specifically this
video this is their why our baby will
only eat fruit video and this what I you
need a youtuber review is gonna be
structured slightly differently than
what I normally do mainly because I
wasn't really able to find a traditional
what I eat in a day video by her most of
her videos just show kind of like fruit
her food halls lots of great footage of
them exploring the rainforests and going
to food markets and superjealous right
now just watching her life but I wasn't
really able to analyze the macros and
the meals like I normally do so I can
tell you about the fit shorty eats duo
soon to be trio is that it consists of
Tina and Simon and they are fruit at
Ariens also call themselves fruit
hunters so apparently that's a real job
in the YouTube world and I'm very
jealous about it but basically they are
expecting their first baby right now so
very exciting times I assume the baby's
already being born and honestly I
thought they are really cute couple I
really enjoyed watching their
interactions they both seemed super
super sweet now one thing I do want to
point out is that a lot of my vegan
followers have asked me not to refer to
their diet as vegan because they very
rightfully so have pointed out that
veganism and fruitarianism are not the
same thing and I get that I get why you
don't want to be associated with that
because one is a dangerous fad in my
opinion and one can be a very healthy
lifestyle black and white not the same
done so in this particular video Tina
suggests that she's going to be feeding
her child a completely fruitarian diet
and this is where the controversy lies
I mean I still no reason why we would
make or I see lots of reasons but we'll
get to that in just a second so first I
want to talk about what a fruitarian
diet actually is so funny little
anecdote when I was a little kid I used
to call myself a fruitarian because like
most kids I loved fruit and while I
probably yes was a picky eater who loved
strawberries I also loved peanut butter
and chicken and broccoli and bread and
pasta and a wide variety of other things
as well so my mom probably thought that
was some kind of cute statement made by
a preschooler 30 years ago but if she
knew what I knew now she probably her
pants at its most restrictive
fruitarians not surprisingly as it
sounds only consumed fruit though some
less aggressive followers also allow
nuts and seeds either way it is a crazy
fad diet with a huge following on social
media and YouTube with over 750 thousand
tags used on Instagram right now it's
crazy
it was also recently made infamous by
Apple CEO Steve Jobs and when Ashton
Kutcher tried it out to get into his
role to play Jobs for a film he ended up
hospitalized so let's take a peek at
what they're eating
okay then well let's talk about the
macros and get right into this because
yes beautiful beautiful fruit here very
refreshing I'm sure but inevitably very
unbalanced so fruit as we know is
basically all carbs so I would
definitely be worried about the other
macros protein and fat in this diet
protein specifically you know because
even the best sources of protein in
fruit are really not that good a cup of
coconut you're looking at 2.7 grams of
protein and avocados 4 grams of protein
and a jackfruit is just 3 grams of
protein so you'd have to eat a lot of
that to meet your needs so having said
that I'll be very concerned about things
like muscle wasting immune function hair
nails skin basically everything in your
body is made up of protein that'll be
another big major concern area for me
and yes you can get lots of great fats
from avocados and coconuts but you
cannot get omega-3 fats and omega-3s
play an integral role in hormone
functioning brain health and heart
health now for baby omega threes
particularly the EPA and DHA Omega 3s
which are types of Omega threes are
really important for baby's cognitive
and visual development and while we can
find omega-3 use the ala omega-3s that's
another type in nuts and seeds aka not
fruit we know that the conversion to EPA
and DHA is not great and that's why we
typically recommend a marine source as
the ideal situation ok so let's talk
about those micronutrients so yes fruit
is super nutritious it's packed with
fiber antioxidants energizing carbs and
lots of micronutrients like vitamins A
and C and this is great because it's
probably the case that she is meeting if
not
eating greatly her needs for fluid and
fiber which is really important when
baby starts messing with your bowel
movements and also getting her fill of
vitamin C which we have increased needs
for in pregnancy due to the formation of
collagen and blood vessels so kudos to
that also one of the major nutrients of
concern in pregnancy is the B vitamin of
folate which helps prevent the formation
of neural tube defects so for that
reason it's recommended that all
pregnant women take a prenatal
supplement with at least 400 micrograms
of folic acid daily now the good news is
that citrus bananas avocados and papaya
are all sources of folate so while would
still be recommended that she takes some
kind of prenatal supplement if she's
eating all those things it's very likely
she's at least getting enough all that
said she's left a lot to be desired
especially for a pregnant lady or her
baby so iron and b12 are probably the
big ones these tend to be concentrated
in animal foods whole grains and in some
veggies we also know that iron needs are
particularly high in pregnancy because
of the increased blood volume and I
don't see a lot of iron rich foods in
Tina's diet I don't really see any
actually as for baby when baby starts to
hit the six-month mark their iron stores
are depleted and even breast milk is not
enough to carry them through with those
next six months so that's why we really
introduce we really suggest that will be
introduced solids we're focusing on iron
rich foods and sadly a baby's just not
gonna meet their needs eating papaya and
rambutan as for b12 I definitely think
this is a big one especially in light of
new research that suggests that low b12
in pregnancy can result in preterm labor
or neural tube defects both things you
don't want calcium and vitamin D are
also really important nutrients for
promoting bone growth in utero and also
preventing rickets or bowed legs in
childhood we've basically eliminated
rickets in developed countries and I
would hate for any child to suffer
through this debilitating condition just
because of poor prenatal or early
childhood nutrition so typically we find
calcium and vitamin D in things like
dairy some nuts and seeds
and fortified items Inc will be another
one I'm worried about it promotes gene
expression and cell growth in pregnancy
it also helps prevent the risk of
infection and growth impairment when
baby starts on solids so this would be
definitely something that I'm concerned
about and you can find zinc in animal
products nuts dairy eggs and whole
grains iodine is another really
important one because it helps produce
the thyroid hormone which is responsible
for growth blood cell production and
muscle function also there is research
to suggest that deficiency of iodine in
pregnancy has been linked to miscarriage
and intellectual disability in the baby
so I would definitely be worried about
this one you can get iodine in a lot of
fish products
whole grains and dairy products so yeah
we need the other major nutrients of
concern include vitamin E which is an
immune boosting nutrient found in nasty
seeds and vitamin K which is really
important for blood coagulation and
that's found in greens now listen one
thing I want to emphasize is that we
know YouTube life is not necessarily a
real life and we only know what we see
in a video so I have no clue if this if
Tina is taking a prenatal supplement or
any other supplements or if she's eating
other things I have no idea one thing I
do want people to know is that a
supplement is just that a supplement to
a healthy well-balanced diet and at this
time there is no magic pill that can
replace the amazing benefits in whole
real food so yes when you're pregnant
you definitely want to make sure that
you're taking a prenatal supplement but
that should not be a replacement for a
balanced healthy lifestyle and diet I
also want to talk about the sheer volume
of sugar in this diet so fruit as we
know is mainly sugar it's actually
predominantly fructose sugar and we
consume an excess of sugar especially in
the absence of any protein or fat to
slow down the absorption we overwork the
pancreas to pump out a ton
insulin so personally I would be
concerned about like pancreatic stress
on a diet like this as well as dental
caries for sure especially because I saw
another video of hers where she said she
never brushes her teeth she just like
eats an apple and it cleans her mouth
now in Tina's case I want to talk about
gestational diabetes I want to make it
very clear that carbohydrates and sugar
do not cause gestational diabetes
however I don't know what her prenatal
care is like out there in the
rainforests and I saw in another video
that Tina is 40 years old which already
puts her at very high risk for
gestational diabetes so if something
like this were to go undetected and
unflagged and she's eating this massive
carb load all day long it could be
really seriously problematic untreated
gestational diabetes can result in
macrosomia which is like a big baby
preterm labor respiratory distress and
type 2 diabetes you don't want to mess
with finally the last thing I want to
say is I just feel like this fruitarian
diet is so restrictive it's putting
forward the wrong message about having a
healthy relationship with food I want to
just play for a second what she has to
say about this changes and why we would
make or need something yeah we are both
Simonon i completely content with the
idea that our children once they grow up
and they
[Music]
we'll explore other phones wherever if
the cooked foods or even not a bit in
the food right because what you put in
your mouth is the biggest one data
station of your personal freedom in this
life I cannot control what you eat and
lend more than you can control what I
eat so how could I you know control with
my child eat so in my child interacts
with our children our you know if he's
done for every value in the face which
we now we've all been for like a
rebellion phase in nineteen eighty years
I'm gonna love you and support him
whenever he's you know food experiments
maybe like wherever he's put experiments
may take him I'm putting food on the
table it's time I hope you know our
children so I do plan on incorporating
information about suffering you know
[Music]
[Music]
finally I want to talk about Tina's
philosophy I really really love and
agree that Tina says that you know food
is a huge part of our identity and it's
the greatest manifestation of who we are
and I also love that she's completely
open the idea of her child eventually
one day making their own choices about
what to eat and kind of exploring that
agency that's awesome so Tina also says
that you know we can't tell her what to
eat the same way that she can't tell us
what to eat and that absolutely is true
and it makes total
when we're talking about consenting
adults not when we're talking about
little children because as a parent that
is our job we are the ones in control of
what they eat will be put on the plate
and what they put on the table that is
our role in the division of
responsibilities of feeding their role
is to just determine what they're going
to eat and how much of it they're going
to eat where we diverge in philosophy is
that Tina seems to believe that she's
doing no harm and it is no harm feeding
a restrictive diet from the get-go and
that you know allowing her kid to have
food freedom many years down the road
when they have their own money and they
can explore the world and they can cook
their own food is the way to go but what
we're talking about here are really
important years for growth and
development when baby starts solids when
baby is eating and growing and moving
through those preschool years that is
when we really need to focus on making
sure that our child is getting a
well-balanced diet if he wants to
consume a fruitarian diet or consume a
carnivore diet or you know not eat
anything at all and just be breathitt
Arian when he's 30 years old then that
is his mo that is his prerogative but we
want to make sure that we are setting
our kids up right for their proper
growth and crop proper development and
also for just fostering a healthy
balanced relationship with food right
from the get-go
so bottom line momma's pregnancy and
those early years of infancy are not the
time for restrictive eating growing a
human both inside you and when they're
out in the world is a huge
responsibility literally every piece of
skin and hair and nails and organ and
muscles all of these things are
literally being grown and manufactured
out of the macro and micronutrients that
you give it and yes I know Tina
mentioned how she's going to be
hopefully doing extended breastfeeding
which is fantastic however breast milk
is only as good as what you put into it
and baby's probably going to leech and
squeeze every nutrient it possibly can
out of that breast milk but if you're
not feeding yourself a really healthy
well-balanced diet
it's not going to yield very fruitful
breast milk if you will and fuel for
baby Tina I think you seem like such a
wonderful warm nurturing woman and I can
just feel the love that you already have
for this baby like radiating through the
screen and I think that is awesome
but for anyone all you moms out there
and families who are on restrictive
diets I think it's just so important
that we recognize the unique dietary and
nutritional needs of our children as
they move through the life stages and
honestly this frigid Aryan diet not only
is it very inadequate but it's actually
quite potentially very dangerous so guys
I hope you enjoyed this video my what I
eat in a day youtuber review if you
loved it be sure to give it a thumbs up
and if you haven't already gotten a
chance to check out all of the other
great what I need a youtuber a few
videos you can check out the iCard right
here
leave me your thoughts on this diet but
also anyone else's diets who you'd love
me to review subscribe to the channel
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye